let's go back to Monday night's MTV VMAs
and John Travolta's crazy mix-up that
went completely viral everyone buzzing
about the moment he seemed to mistake a
drag queen for Taylor Swift but John
says it's not how it looked there are so
many people that were barred of the
stage that I was looking for her so the
video has me looking behind her but
thought it was so funny the way it was
interpreted and it was cool I did again
Travolta is laughing off the whole
Taylor drag queen mixed up he says he
was in on the joke and his only regret
not taking it further tell you sometimes
fantasize what if I'm giving it to her
have been awesome like I should have
just like gone all the way with it
there's 65 year old actor says he's used
to the scrutiny I shaved my head it's
headlines sure I'm mispronouncing its
headlines buzzie my whole life for
whatever reason it's the Liz Taylor Club
you know you wear a different dress you
wear a different hairstyle your headline
news so what did Taylor think
taylors pal todrick Hall says the
popstar loved it he was so confident
that it was her we talked about it
backstage and then Taylor thought it was
hilarious and the viral attention is all
good with Travolta he told Dallas radio
station hot 93.3 he looks at the bright
side look we're in pretty good shape on
the day any given day that that kind of
thing could make headlines that means it
at least for today there's no bad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]